ورائي هو الموضوع الذي نتحدث
عنه ، ويعتقد أنه خلف هذا
القماش المشمع الذي تراه هناك
جسم ، يبدو أنه على
وشك أن يتم من قبل الشرطة المحلية ، فإن
المنطقة بأكملها الآن قد
تتخيلها كحد أقصى
لقد تم تطويقه بشكل جيد وحقيقيًا في الواقع ، لقد قاموا بتطويقه على
طول الطريق حتى الطريق السريع من أمستردام
حيث أتينا ،
وقد استغرق الأمر بعضًا من المرور عبر المنطقة
وقد تم وضعه قيد الإغلاق إلى حد كبير
، ولا يوجد أحد حوله بشكل واضح باستثناء
التواجد المكثف للشرطة بالضبط
ما حدث بالطبع هو أنه لم
يتم تحديده بعد ، من الواضح أنك
أبلغت عما قاله رئيس
الوزراء ولكن في الوقت الحالي يجب عليك
الابتعاد عن الطريق حتى تحصل على فكرة أوضح
بشكل أفضل عما  حدث ذلك
وهو الصعلوك
حيث يُعتقد أن إطلاق
النار كان في طريقه إلى
وسط أوتريخت ، وهناك ترام آخر
على يميني ولكن هذا لا نعتقد
أنه مناسب على هذا النحو.  من الواضح
أن هذا كان مجرد بارك في المحطة المحلية ،
فإن القماش المشمع الذي نراه الآن والذي
يمكنك رؤيته الآن هو أننا نعتقد وفقًا
لأولئك الموجودين هنا قبلي هو في الواقع
يحمي ما هو جسد ولكن حتى
الآن لا نعرف تفاصيل أخرى عن ذلك
هناك طائرات هليكوبتر تحلق باستمرار في
سماء المنطقة ويزداد تواجد الشرطة
كل دقيقة